good evening an uptick in immigration
scams have some local community
leaders on alert tonight welcome back to
8 news now at 6 30 i'm bryan loftis
and i'm christian casadas denise is on
assignment tonight they say
notarios are preying on undocumented
people looking to get legal status
in the country it becomes really
dangerous for immigrants
because one wrong move on an immigration
application
one wrong move on a form and this could
put an individual
in jeopardy of deportation it's a scam
that's very common among the
undocumented community
they call themselves notarios who
promised to help folks
resolve their immigration problems but
end up doing the opposite in latin
american countries the notario
is someone that is seen as like a
magistrate you know
upwards of a high level judge depending
on what part of latin america you're in
leo murray is with make the road nevada
and says this problem spikes with
every new white house administration
because people are hopeful for a change
in immigration policies there is very
little if any path to legalization
naturalization for the majority of
undocumented people
so offering them hope is what
these bad actors prey on some red flags
to watch out for
are pop-up services according to
murietta and being put on a wait list
a registry or being told get in while
it's good
a false sense even he fell for i myself
am a victim of notario fraud
when i tried to naturalize myself in
2007
i trusted my church and i ended up
spending
over six thousand dollars over the
course of three years
well the best recommendation is to seek
help from a trusted attorney or a
community based organization
because becoming a victim can hurt your
wallet and even cause deportation